foreign
[Music]
David
nice to see you again hello
so where did you grow up
where were you and what did what did
childhood
look like so the two of us were born in
Moscow
still 17 at that time
to a family of
the very known neuroscientists
like by physicists who like the family
were sort of like upper middle class for
the Soviets
measure yeah right
but as soon as the Soviet Union
collapsed we with the Soviet Union the
family collapsed to the Beloved already
type of situation because our dad was
born in 1925. so in 1990 he was pretty
old already
and didn't had a chance to adapt to the
new reality it was six of us it was
elementary school kids so a complicated
situation both of parents had to
continue the work as they wanted
actually to finalize and finish
the work of their life and at the same
time somehow survive and Fit Kids and
like get some clothes for us and stuff
and it's like six of us one year apart
our mom was mom she was busy busy busy
with making her breakthrough Works in in
how neuron neurons works and the
signaling system in the neurons at the
same time having six of us in in what in
eight years less than eight years yes
how did she so I started interrupt like
how does any human do that so let alone
a mom you know not to get us into all
these confusing gender Waters but let's
just say for the time being Mom primary
caregiver would that be fair to say yes
yes so how did she manage both the
scientific Exploration with this
groundbreaking work and six kids I can
barely manage one dog what qualifies as
my job so how did she do that I think
that after the fourth one
we kind of a little bit managed
ourselves right right but still it's not
the answer for the question because no
there was a Grant Line Grandpa from time
to time so so from time to time they
would drop half of us at the grandpa in
Grandma's place and then took the half
of us with them to the laboratory that's
how we spend a lot of time surrounded by
the fish and snails
we were surrounded by all this equipment
and lasers they got first PC is much
earlier than anyone else that's why like
we also were quite
excited about that
and I think that's in general they were
super passionate about their work that's
what we definitely picked from our
parents and about each other so there
were six of us that's for sure it's a
full team yeah it's a full soccer team
so you have lots of excitement
maybe lots of chaos you have goldfish
snail grandparents lasers sounds like a
pretty awesome setup for Curious Kids
honestly and
what did you pick up
on intellectually as a way of thinking
from your parents and I asked that
because I know both of you for instance
and I'm not trying to lead with this
question but pay a lot of attention to
data your your sort of Geeks for parsing
the data whether it's to like refine how
you think about or identify problems and
then also how you might solve problems
what did You observe
in your parents or pick up from them
when it came to how they thought about
things now that you said that I realized
that
our parents were doing those experiments
which required them years of repeating
repeating repeating repeating the same
stuff like trying to get data which
would make sense on top of their
hypothesis of how everything works
so I guess we've been surrounded by the
papers piles of papers with just numbers
literally I remember this
how was it called is this
oh like the the punch card The Punch
Cards yeah yeah the Punch Cards like
everywhere The Punch Cards like before
the PC was there there were like this
huge type
recording machines with all the data as
well
and like but what's interesting most of
them was always challenging the status
quo of of the current understanding of
of science so if just someone claims
something and you cannot really prove it
for yourself with data probably
something is missing and you need to dig
deeper and that's how they lived and
they had their own discussions with
everyone around and we sort of picked it
up as we were growing already like I
don't know 15 ish years old or that was
even older so he needed someone to
escort him to the conferences and like
meetings of scientists just basic like
it's it's Moscow and winter and the
roads are icy yeah I don't know five six
months a year like something like
something like this so so he needed
someone to to basically help him get
there
and being there all the time we saw his
conversations with the rest of the
scientific community in the in his
Institute
as they were just like laughing
out of nowhere I mean just like be like
oh yeah of course like again labor man
is talking about the quantum nature of
of of the Consciousness blah blah blah
blah something like that so we're like
looking at this it's like why he has
some ideas and proofs so it was sort of
the resistance resistance to the rest
the rest of the world we felt his
resistance and we like were challenged
with this as we're like oh we're gonna
prove everyone
he remembers against the world Libra
moves against the world exactly so as
far as a next logical place I mean I
like hopping around because I see things
on paper I find certain things exciting
to talk about and then we can fill in
the gaps so I'm just gonna actually
answer my own question and I'm gonna
take you to
around and then we can fill in the gaps
as we go so you're around 18 to 19 years
old and you're presenting to Russian
Parliament what do you what are you
presenting about and how is the
reception
yes so a little bit of background so
sure after Soviet Union collapsed
the entire population of the country
even lost their Savings in the banks
like twice during the decade yeah so it
was a quite harsh time for for everyone
and for us it was
strange strange like we
weren't able to understand how with all
the modern Technologies with computers
and Etc how it's all like how was this
corruption in how it's even possible
yes definitely some technologies
should be there should be there to solve
these problems we had internet pretty
early and we were hikers like pretty I
mean it was at that time of of the
internet era when everything was
possible yeah access to everything was
possible so at that moment we read lots
of the high cares Manifesto since some
like libertarian ideas wandering around
the internet and we saw all these ideas
of of
decentralized type of data storage which
which can be Pro like
from
from like from various attacks or
attacks and modifications like
falsifications right it's resilient
against falsification yes resilient
against falsification like a blockchain
type of ideas before Satoshi actually
released his first paper on the Block
Chain which wasn't which was never the
one word it was a like block like chain
of blocks but victorians and other types
about this we're circulating over the
Internet so with this combination of
those ideas we came up to a solution as
we thought before like eradicating
corruption in Russia to make all of the
governmental expenses completely
transparent
stored on the people's machines stories
in the people's machines so that no none
of the corrupt officials can actually
even do anything with with the data
so we are presenting this idea
and pretty soon when people realize what
we are talking about they basically
asked us to go out like just like shut
down the mic he's like the meeting is
over thank you so much sorry we're
having some technical difficulties
and then the guy who actually invited us
he was some sort of a deputy for the
head of the party at the time at the
time there was multiple parties not only
like United Russia
but this guy came
like approach approach this in the
corridor saying boys I can see you are
very smart and all these ideas are just
brilliant but stop talking about this
[__] otherwise someone will kill you
like no no no not ask like we're good
guys but there are bad people who are
making lots of money and this is against
what they want
okay so now at that point do you do you
do you pretty immediately pivot to
something else
pretty immediately we realize that what
we need to Pivot into is grassrooting
those ideas instead of trying to make
them
top to bottom approach it's quite it's
quite it's quite the missionaries of
anti-corruption distribute the risk but
it is no it's like to be quite clear
that
people in the government will never ever
and on those people who really can adapt
those ideas
it was another story to that that's in a
week after that they actually invited us
again to to come and like we came in and
they
asked us to work on a project and said
well like what is the project answer
that oh you you talk you mentioned
something about this realization and how
is it this realization can be anonymous
at the same time can you create an
anonymous
HR agency which will sell seats in
government
and we're like wait what he's like yes
yes so like imagine people who actually
making lots of money and who's capable
of paying lots of money for a sit in the
government they are people who like
business competitors and manage better
like they can manage stuff better than
us so like just from the street yeah
just just happened to be here just by
chance because someone was like a friend
of someone so if we actually invite
people who did something in business and
have money to pay for the for the
position in government they can do a
better job for the for the country our
first reaction was like we really have
uh price prices for that yes yes yes for
sure like can you give us an example and
the guy was like
Deputy Minister of Finance was half a
million dollar wow and minister of
healthcare I know it's College ecology
was three million dollars
the question was immediately psychology
no one give a [__] about ecology in
Russia it's like exactly that's how the
person who will take the position will
have a return on investment pretty much
use all this like fancy words they'll
get their money back pretty much in a
year on bribes
so we quite soon realized that they they
you're like well we appreciate the
invitation appreciate the invitation
never call us again yeah thank you
that's our reaction
but yes that's
a moment when we decided to Pivot to
building our own businesses and making
services
and then building type of Technologies
ourselves then you can buy the ministry
of ecology one day one day
or we can like like the the revolution
or something like that now at that point
you while you're observing all this
and it's imprinting your young minds are
you thinking eventually
we are going to want to build businesses
somewhere else or did you anticipate
that you would be building in Russia for
the foreseeable future how are you
thinking about things at that point you
know for us somehow at this particular
moment it was still an original
unreachable and the idea is that we can
fly somewhere and build businesses sorry
like it's only years after that we
we start to be more confident in our
abilities and I start to think about
that it was miserable like the first
time we flew to United States just on
our own miserable experience a very low
level like full level of English no
understanding whatsoever what the
country looks like and what's going on
we're trying to raise Investments we
were trying to raise Investments
miserable
that sounds like a hard slog of a first
trip
okay so so at the time then you're just
focused on building businesses and what
type of business were you building at
that point we had like ideas
our first company
was in ISP internet service provider it
was kind of we wanted to have a good
internet connection and it was super
unaffordable like five thousand dollars
to connect your apartment
wow so like it sounds very unreachable
Instagram especially for the family of
eight people who was making like couple
hundred dollars a month for the
household it was unreachable so at some
point we realized that if we want to
have a such level of internet in our at
our own apartment what we can do we can
go through all of the neighbors
and it was like what 1600 1600
apartments in the like in the
small District small like District yeah
like it's quite like the neighborhood
the neighborhood yeah like a dense
neighborhoods of Norwich in Moscow and
uh
we literally rang all the doorbells and
were like the question was like do you
have a computer if the answer was yes do
you know what internet is if the answer
was no like okay let us explain you
let's have some tea anyways you'll
literally sneaking into people's
apartment and starting to explain them
what they are losing by not having
Internet already connected to their
computer so we present couple hundreds
contracts and with that we're like okay
we can now go to the bank
get a
house called alone
consumer alone just like basically
consumer loan and we use them on it to
buy all the equipment to buy the cable
like the
Optics fiber yeah fiber optic cable
fiber optic cable and basically connect
all these households and people paid and
we covered them like the loan pretty
fast like it's still it's still
was a quite challenging project so I'm
wondering just what you're buying with
the loans you're buying like servers
sticking them in a bathroom or like how
do how is it being connected to the
existing infrastructure first we needed
basically someone to bring the cable in
it was the most expensive part of the
operation digging trenches
we hired the engineering team we were
lucky because the largest sort of Hub
Hub communication hub for their Moscow
internet was basically two kilometers
away from us that's great look it's a
great lot we we because our parents from
science we were in the part of Moscow
there were lots of scientists before in
the universities were there as well and
that's why makes sense like makes an
internet first emerged at this point so
I hired these people the engineering
team to bring the cable and then
by night mostly we were connecting
like 20 story buildings to each other by
shooting the cable using the athletic
air ball let me just oh like a crossbow
crossbow yeah it just local officials
local officials they were bribed by the
bigger player
in the
didn't allow us to actually they
wouldn't give us a kiss
to the Roof Center properly yeah
competition competition was there even
though we had the license and by law
they couldn't prohibit us to do this but
they were like not allowing us that's
why at night we would sneak onto the
roof like pretty like dangerous
operation of getting onto the roof even
without having an access through the
through the door and then from the roof
to the roof we basically were like
putting these cables
a shooting from one roof to another roof
this company was then acquired by a
bigger player there was a significant
consolidation on the market so between
between the ninja crossbow expansion and
the acquisition how long did that take
two years like two years two years all
right yeah moving fast moving fast then
the later on we realized that what we
actually need to do is
super Computing like we were like we are
smart in mathematics we can build out
like we can write algorithms and this is
something like we foreseen the future of
cloud computing using like machines in
Internet
to like parallelize compute over the
like this was our idea originally then
we realized that like it's impossible to
do in Russia type of the business
and we decided that what we can do we
can start building games
now before you go on was the computer
science and like whatever coding
experience you had was that self-taught
was it school was it parents our college
degree is computer science yeah but in
reality
in Russia at this moment
no one will really
teach you properly lame
computer science because you're
you're teachers will no less than you I
say if you haven't if you're motivated
we were like you
because of our parents or scientists we
got PCS at our home much earlier than
most of our peers we've got internet now
how much Arizon most of our peers and we
were
super excited about this technology
serious and
how to say naughty so it would break the
computers all the time and we had to fix
them all the time for the parents to
continue their work and that's how we
actually learn how to build our first
website to for our guilt in online
gaming like ultimate online every choice
curious and naughty that can be the name
of your autobiography
The Life and Times
[Laughter]
okay so you have the consolidation and
then you decide to focus on games after
that yes and what form did that take we
played ultimate online
we were super excited about this type of
games we thought that this is Revolution
because people just hang out there you
know like there is no like
aim or or you don't need to just kill
all these messages just people hang out
sandbox you can have a marriage there
build a house Second Life
instead of Doom instead of Doom exactly
as we are very excited about this but
had to play only overnight because of
dial up connection and the phone was for
everyone in the apartment for us at
night that's why we actually wanted the
better internet all the time and that's
how the ISP started so then when we
decided to build such game at that
moment this idea
was really and not popular most of the
you even can find some quotes from CEO
of electronic electronic cards who would
say like online games is just a niche
market it will never be big online games
and and all this stuff
he actually was apologized like many
years officially admitted he was wrong
many years later I mean that's very
honest honest a lot of people don't own
those he's like he is he was like he was
he was super cool and that he was like I
said that I was wrong like nah we are in
the game yeah so and we tried to launch
several one time failed our own savings
spend all of our own savings
World of Warcraft
was released and we were the only ones
who were for years
for such type of the project and that's
why it's got all the attention this
moment in we released our first so World
of Warcraft comes out it's a proof of
concept yes for what you are also trying
to pursue in a way not only proof of
concept it was the first game ever
netting one billion dollar of profit a
year it was just
I think people outside of games also
today do not realize how big the numbers
are yes like the opening weekend for the
new Call of Duty compared to like every
Hollywood Blockbuster for a six-month
period or something like that the
numbers are astronauts this Market was
really for years larger than the movie
Market yeah but
15 years ago it was not as obvious yes
but it was already obvious that it can
make lots of money so we were able to
convince some of the investors investors
tend to like that
and we got a lot of attention grew
pretty fast to 150 to 100 new place in
different times
but then 2008 crisis came and adjusted
so and we were not ready I mean
World of Warcraft it took blizzard the
the top game development studio in the
world
that what we didn't realize when we
started it took them like five six years
to build quite complicated with an army
with an army and unlimited resources
and us we're like we can do it with like
couple million dollars
okay we were miserable in this in this
case but honestly in this experience we
realized that that we can be cool in in
developing
sort of uh cheap cheat
like not cheating but how to say it
hacking hacking our way through the
challenges yeah inventing new stuff
inventing how we can build and yeah
[Music]
Etc and even though we bankrupt the
company in 2009 by March 2009 I had to
fire everyone like 150 people in one day
sounds fun super fun the most
challenging the emotional my experience
of our life brutal and then three four
months later we already started an
animation studio and used all of the
ideas which came to our mind during this
period like we can actually do this and
this and that we wouldn't do this in the
games but we can do this in in the
animation process if you're able to take
things from that the failed gaming
studio and transfer them over into the
in terms of experience of experiences
most of the experience of like lesson
was learned we knew how to do stuff
better as we were progressing from
knowing nothing when we started to
basically having like a pretty
sophisticated production process
we immediately reinvented the animation
process so we basically took the guy who
was experienced in producing 3D graphics
and was like okay why don't we change it
all why we why don't we take what you
know and then try to figure out how to
make it much more efficient
how did you decide on that
versus the 100 other things that you
might first of all it was a super
challenging time like the company was
bankrupt we by that time we actually
already were quite successful in
different stuff we already have started
a venture winter raised 30 million
dollars to the Venture firm but this
Venture form
was took over by our investors of the
gaming studio
the security people from the from the
person's arrived at the office took us
in the like black cars driving us to the
underground
of the
what is like office building in in the
middle of Moscow and then threatening us
that they will kill us and our family
because we know where everyone lives
unless we'll return the money this type
of business experience Hardline strict
investors in in that moment we we knew
that we need to with a new projects we
need to do something fast because we
still had some
obligations
in place which we just fired because we
haven't paid the salary for last month
the outstanding that was like half a
million dollars so we were still living
with our parents so we use that that we
don't want to have investors anymore and
they see like all this experience which
we had we wanted to do something which
can generate cash right away not like
another apartment building basements yes
yes and then there was a luck because a
friend of ours who is a famous actress
in Russia
he told the CEO the president of channel
one which is like NBC or Russia like the
largest Network or like one of the BBC
channels in the UK 2018 exactly exactly
that we can do magic wheels
how did you become friends with the
actress
friends of friends introduce us and like
we basically become super cool friends
we're like writing scripts together for
the future movies and stuff but in
reality I'm not sure that she really
knew that we can do that
she was very confident he was that we we
fixed her internet
goes a long way
so she sells this head of the you know
the this primary channel that you guys
can do you can work magic with we work
magic and yeah we're doing magic with
Graphics but for games and he wanted to
create
a political satire show which would be
based on the last week events which is
impossible animation usual production
cycle is
9 to 12 months
production is actually like three four
months but then they leave this several
minutes for something topical which they
can produce over a couple weeks right
before the episode is released like
they're doing this in that South Park
they're the fastest they're the fastest
exactly and we invented the production
process which allowed us to produce half
hour animated show 3D Graphics in one
week
how did you do that the interesting part
was we just basically disassembled the
entire process on smaller pieces and
parallelized them this idea of
decentralization and parallelization was
like
we couldn't live it right so rather than
an assembly line type of production
you're like how how many of these can we
have running in parallel were you able
to borrow resources from the channel to
work on those parallels no no we
actually at the time were able to borrow
resources from IBM okay how's that work
a friend of ours was the president of
IBM of Russia and we agreed that they
will be DJ in the club during the
weekends that's how we knew the guy
you never know who's DJing at the club
make friends DJing at night and they're
like during the weekends and then and in
a suit like a serious president of IBM
during the weekdays that's crazy that's
crazy and the guy was like I [__]
laugh what you're doing so I'm sorry can
I say this oh yeah and like he was like
yes I'll give you the equipment and they
gave us like a
I don't know what was it it was around
like a million dollars or server servers
with the idea that they will give us
this equipment not permanently but for
some time for free
yeah that IBM will use the fact that
this show was created with the most
Innovative for sure it was created it
gives us equipment but IBM decided that
it's too political and they never even
used it because the show was political
attire in Russia so the hell like the
headquarter in the United States was
like no no no we don't that does not
sound low risk
they allowed us to use the equipment but
never put the logo in there okay so they
allow you to use the equipment and then
was the president just like look we're
gonna forget it's there for a while you
guys can use it yes yes it was exactly
like very helpful DJ we made the first
season using that equipment but then
already
like the channel one paid us like three
million dollars for the first season and
with that money we were able to buy all
the equipment we needed food like half a
million to the employees yes the first
we paid the half a million it was
Advanced payments so we came to channel
ones like we needed bus payment they're
like why it was like the processes
and we basically paid the debts wow okay
so what happens then so you have you
have this parallel processing that's
working with your
semi-permanently borrowed IBM machines
from the DJ you make three million you
you manage to negotiate prepayments so
you satisfy your outstanding debts to
paying the ex-employees and then what
the summer was hard work yes but this
was the first time when we actually
start to earn enough of our own funds
and we return to first we return to our
ideas that we need to think about
what type of Technologies can be created
too are you guys not afraid
just for your personal or Family Safety
we still are not honestly the part of us
not being afraid probably somehow was
related to our dad was never afraid of
whoever was challenging him but at the
same time back in 2000 when as we
finished the school
we knew that if we have all these ideas
of changing the world it's going to be
impossible if we just stay home play
computer games and stuff so we decided
we would go to some business trainings
personal development trainings fear
trainings like oh we started challenging
ourselves in developing ourselves and by
five like 2005. we spent like four years
developing our own internal Equanimity
well let's talk about this Equanimity
for a second because this is super
important and it's sort of the enabler
or the handicapper the lack of it being
a handicapper
in so many different capacities and I
would say
a lot of the people listening to this
are going to be from the U.S and
fortunately for them they have never had
the experience of being under a
political regime where people disappear
but I've spent a lot of time in South
America or poisoned or fill in the blank
yeah disappears in quotation marks and
but what you realize is there are
political regimes all around the world
very common where people routinely are
killed poisoned or otherwise made to
disappear so
the risks were very real for you these
are not
conspiracy theories like there are
actual threats so was the lack of fear
a lack of fear of death or was it a
belief that you could extricate yourself
or avoid
any type of like really significant
consequence or something else there are
three answers to that a yes we don't be
afraid to die okay somehow don't I mean
this is like yudai that's it whatever be
somehow and it actually really helped
with the bandits in 2009 when they when
they came to ask for all of their money
invested in the game back
we knew that it's their way of
threatening you and they want you to be
afraid they want you to fear and that's
how you're on a hook
that's how you're controlled that's when
they like hook you and they and you owe
them forever and we show them that like
if I can't kill us whatever I mean like
you will never get your money back and
the other case like we can probably work
it out somehow and we learned through
this experience that actually if you
don't show the fear is much safer
then if you show it's a little bit like
with lions blood in the water yes yes
but then the third one the third one is
when it comes to the political systems
as like let's say particularly Russian
political system for the KGB people who
were actually running the country at
that time like putting this ax head of
KGB like that's what that's the only
thing which we all should understand
that the country ran by KGB people
yes they call themselves FSB but who's
to give a [__] like it's it's KGB it's
the same guys
like who were just basically killing
people 60 50 years before that in Russia
after the war before the war
so
so when it comes to them they see two
type of people who are
playing against them it's either enemies
or idiots
fools enemies
like your eyes work on your eyes
or you're an idiot who was convinced by
CIA to fight against them and you're
just like fool who who like your pawn
pawn so we played the pawn card we're
like let's show ourselves as if we're
stupid
and we were completely transparent about
all of our ideas from the very beginning
saying like they will just see us as a
as fools right lunatics strategy work
work
anymore officially look at what we know
people like that who already
but at that particular time it's a time
it was just so rare that they were like
oh these guys are just crazy because we
made it transparently if you are a say
agent you will try to hide but if you
like transfer money to the biggest
position here like transparently right
away from an article writing an article
in the largest newspaper Financial Times
yes and they're like oh idiots they
spend their money okay whatever we'll
just steal this money from the
positioner anyway so fools that was the
situation for so for us the shield for
all this years was like they believe
we're just idiots
incredible all right we may come back to
this but I wanna I wanna make sure I
don't lose the thread so the graphics
for this political satire
seems to be working pretty well you
return to your ideas from prior which is
how we got here so thinking about
anti-corruption and things like that
we already established our presence in
Los Angeles because of Animation 2010 in
2010 and started to move our own
attention all attention to so we were
like United States nothing good going to
happen in the country
it's ran by the KGB and will like they
they're not going to release their
grasp over the country unless it's going
to be like a a revolution type of
situation which we saw that even a
position they were trying to play the
political game and it was a lost game
from the very beginning
so we knew that the show political
satire on largest TV network in Russia
is not going to last more than the the
term of President puppet president
that's exactly what happened like as
soon as it Putin get back to his
position like the show was shut down
immediately so
so we knew it's gonna end and we knew
that we need to spend all of the money
which we'll make from this in order to
transit to United States so two
questions and it might seem obvious to
you guys but I think for a lot of people
listening they might wonder well why not
Europe why not somewhere else why why
the U.S and then was it how hard was it
or how easy to start to move your lives
to the U.S you know in Europe especially
animation industry
is it's mostly supposedly subsidized by
governments
so you actually need to deal with
bureaucrats and you need to to get
continue fighting in the the the private
sector almost doesn't exist
so I would say that it makes it very
hard for immigrants yes exactly yes and
it was always like if you wanted local
you need to work with local students and
they should get this funding and like we
started developing the relationship but
even faster we realized that in
Hollywood we have we have all the
chances in pretty quickly we were
introduced to people who then introduced
us to the agencies and William worse
Endeavor signed up with us January 2010
early yeah so but on the trajectory
in the US half a year after we started
the company you know it's still a
challenging process any any immigration
is a challenging process it took us six
years so people really take us seriously
and to get to the same type of level of
professional acceptance like then we had
back in Moscow but we found our ways I
mean at least it is possible here you
know like in the airport like in UK you
would never become you would never be
able to to spend only five six years and
get into the like major universities
California you know California has a lot
of downsides but it's it's one of the
upsides is like this is true in a lot of
the US like no one is
discriminating against Green yeah and
people like opportunity and also
California a lot of people don't realize
part of the reason Silicon Valley worked
is that California also makes it very
hard to enforce non-compete yes
contracts right so so every there are
opportunities everywhere of all
different types yeah we agree it was a
completion this was our observations
that's it's all about like non-competes
that they are not enforceable that this
allow you to actually
work at Google write your own search
engine at night and then launch your own
search engine and Google cannot do
really anything there's a lot of free
flow yes which makes it hard sometimes
to retain talent in Silicon Valley but
that's a whole separate story so you
land in LA
you have introductions to people that
say William Morris Endeavor and other
places
what happens is that momentum starts
building we actually had a pretty good
success working with different Studios
and different big names like Jimmy
Fallon we worked on the on on the show
with him at some point we met with
the guy who used to be John Stewart's a
head writer and he just moved back from
New York to Los Angeles
and was sort of available ish he wasn't
for a year but then a year later he was
available and we like we took our chance
to become friends over the year and then
when he become available like Josh
why don't you work with us
and we managed to convince him because
we showed him how fast we actually can
produce animation so we realized that he
we would realize people even like
William Morris Endeavor or Josh even
being the friend for us for like a year
they never actually believed that we can
produce animation in one week and we
have to prove it like literally by
saying like George are you serious okay
just let's write a script right now at
one pager you will write one pager joke
in a week will you will have it an
animation and that's what we did and it
was like whoa you guys were saying you
guys can actually do it you guys can
actually do like before that he worked
at Simpson before John Stewart and it
seems since like 12 months like a year
you're like you're making a joke and
it's already old a year old joke and
with us there was an opportunity for him
to make jokes
which are Super current so it was cool
but on the other hand really wanted to
focus more on the Technologies which can
transform society and plus Hollywood's
wasn't really our thing you know like
there are some trade-offs no one cares
about technologists especially that time
you know like it's before Netflix and
before all the stuff no one cared about
technologist no one cares at you faster
in cheaper
oh wait what you need to know divorce
lawyers yes because they know people
like they know like support Dynamics and
oh this is good for me to know there's
like a power Dynamic of like the divorce
lawyers who who control I picked up a
new stratagem today thank you exactly
okay
so are you all the lawyers and we
started to know the people and we
started to meet the people and
eventually we we
deconstructed what the show needed to be
in order to come to a meeting
in Fox at Fox okay so you were at that
point then you're pitching your own show
yes so we get to the point understanding
that we cannot sell our technology we
have to sell the entire shop we package
it we should package voice a trojan
horse with the technology exactly we
took it all like we that's why we needed
Josh because we needed a head writer
that like we took the voice actors we
took like the the best
concept
artists artists like to to combine the
salt and produce a pilot if like a
literal final quality pilot and brought
it to Fox and who was it Susanna Marcus
at the time she was like wow I love it
because we actually knew what she likes
who she likes what type of artists what
type of artists whether like we we like
engineer data data data and then went to
a Custom Tailor to put together a pilot
for her yes exactly but it was also some
Distortion Misfortune time because
you're like putting it back to Power so
our show was canceled back in Russia in
the banking crisis in Cyprus
all our money was
nationalized so yeah hold on a second so
Cyprus so you had does that mean that
you had moved your finances from Russia
to Cyprus yeah and then it was out of
out of the out of the pan and Into the
Fire yes and then Cyprus got
nationalized and was like oh
the same story all over again yes same
story six million dollars like
ouch earned and all of
all of a sudden we couldn't pay anyone
in the United States no voice actors no
screenwriters like we couldn't pay
anyone immediately it all fell apart
they were sitting there and like all
right are we gonna do it again here we
know everything but so did you get the
green light for the pilot yeah and then
Cyprus yes and then yes bye-bye and we
try to think what we can do in Hollywood
more for like half a year a year but
then we realized it it will take us
another four or five years to recover
because there's no money there's like
nothing in there so like screw it we're
not gonna stay in Hollywood let's move
to Silicon Valley
and also we really already wanted to
return to our real like ideas we we
started with transparency again we
decided that we can do a trick that we
can actually not Target governments to
become transparent but targets
non-profits
like why we don't see how non-profits
actually spend our money it's kind of
obvious it's not your like personal
money it's like we all together gather
These funds to make change world a
better place
so we created a transparent banking
platform for non-profits for many
reasons
we were wrong about the
the
ability and Readiness of the appetite
the appetite exactly the appetite for
the nonprofits but but you know like
this was one of the this was also the
times when we realized that some of the
challenges which like fundamental
challenges which we saw in United States
economy
actually they were true in the United
States as well not only in Europe not
only like in Russia not only is Israel
but in in the United States as well
and we realized that even with the
non-profit
transparency like if you will look at
research or what actually donors want
you will see that the previous
generations of donors
they don't really want to see where the
money spans it's like it's almost yes
yes it almost the last item in the list
of their preferences is the requirements
but our generation and generations
younger
yeah in the first place we want to see
what happened with the dynamic of
thinking behind this is as for the older
generation they donate money because
it's a give back for them they're like
it's feeling good versus doing good yes
maybe and for the youngest is well given
forward they don't we want to change
what's bad right now and we want to see
it's changing yes and also actually
previous generations got a lot from
society
in terms of form of free education
almost free college education like 30
years ago anything like that new
generation being
hammered with a student that's
Etc they don't really feel that Society
gives them much
but they really still donate the same
portion sure of the share the uh
generation but it's just different
reasons I feel like the some of the
younger Generations here younger than
certainly than me get a bad reputation
for misunderstood reasons or I should
say they're misunderstood in the sense
that and I know you guys have spoken
about this before but so if you look at
say previous generations ability to
get a higher education put a down
payment on the house and pay for a
mortgage compared to some of the more
recent Generations it's night and day
yes yes it's night and day so it's it's
important to factor that into how you
evaluate them so question for you guys
with the the look at the non-profit and
this and the the platform right you have
you you're very good at it seems like
letting go of ideas having a light grasp
on ideas if things are not working so
you can move to something else that you
think might work better yes that's not
true for everyone right some people get
very attached to one thing and they want
to ride it until they die and they get
attached to things that may never work
and I'm wondering how you think about
changing direction
maybe failure and quotation marks like
what allows you to do that so readily
data data
we'll learn the hard way yeah so the
first the game Studio we grasp
and then if you don't stop at the right
moment you can actually get to it yeah
yeah you can get into a hole yes but
also what we saw in the data is that
in what we realize also through the
experience of game development failure
and then animations success that we
realized that
it is not always about your ideal
businesses so you can fail yes because
of a different reasons like
poker the time you have to study the
decision making not just the outcomes
yes in the statistics of
Venture startups is that two-thirds like
two-thirds will fail
like completely fail losing all the
money zero and if you will look at all
these failures there are rare exceptions
but in most cases what you should see is
that if your startup is growing you
should continue you should like double
down with your all attention there Etc
if it's not but if it's not I think
let's stop and probably
from the perspective of statistics
if it's not doubled the growth if if
whatever numbers behind your
understanding of of your business
isn't doubled I didn't double I have to
say isn't that it didn't double over
what period of time over 14 months 14
months 14 months I have to ask if you
look at the statistics
doubling over 14 months if you take all
of them and divide then just 14 months
because if you're also not growing with
this this space Venture Capital will not
be accessible to you and you won't be
able to actually raise money use a smart
business funds to go further and things
like that so this Market is is actually
a pretty
special in terms of these probabilities
like just one out of hundred it's going
to be unicorn success and if you don't
see transaction to get there
probably probably not getting the rights
the right I think it's just to stop and
start something here and knowing that
your chances are 1 and 100 you should
try as many attempts as possible take
more shots
we usually show to the young
we show this picture of Mark Zuckerberg
or Evan Spiegel who made into success
from the first attempt dropping out from
the college and look they're
billionaires most of the billion dollar
companies created not like that it's
created by people who failed multiple
times multiple times and then got to
success in in terms of statistics this
is what we should observe with this
definitely something depends on your
abilities to execute Etc but there are
things which
I mean I remember Angel Investing
starting in 2008 and and seeing business
models
companies that couldn't execute in a
period of time because technology just
wasn't there and the adoption wasn't
there and then five six years later
basically the exact same company just
but a few things have changed mobile
phones have become more powerful a
handful of protocols have been developed
and then boom it works Uber is mobile
phone with GPS yeah you're right yes
right
enough adoption yeah in in it was tried
these ideas
online yes for sure it's been there yeah
totally in in because of that you know
especially because we really like you
know we balance ourselves between
sometimes when we work on some
forward-looking ideas like
flying cars wrong something which is not
happening yet and and also we work on
some projects which down to earth which
already something which is happening and
we know that with this project which are
not there yet yes
there is a
with the chance to win big but this
chance is small
and there is like a lot of timings
and you can lose just because timing is
not right
and we as Daniel mentioned we learned it
hard way with game development Studio it
was really hard for us to stop even
though it was obvious that probably we
were lucky with the animation studio and
then another
unfortunate event with losing all of the
money just in banking crisis in Cyprus
and we stopped pretty fast I mean we're
like okay are we gonna spend time
recovering or are we just starting
something new yeah when Silicon Valley
valid Bank Crisis happen we were among
like really small
group of our friends founders
who all this time
we were obsessed with diverse
and everyone would tell us that on like
in the United States you shouldn't think
about that don't worry about this
because Canada right yeah I'm surprised
we are not immune from all the problems
we've seen in other places all right so
I'm gonna I'm gonna zoom out for a
second because I I like to think about
sort of meta decisions that span across
a lot of
other decisions and projects and so on
so the two of you living one life I we
have to talk about this I've never seen
an example quite like this I mean there
are there are couples who are say power
couples but it's a different Dynamic I
mean you guys have been seemingly sort
of hive mind for a very early age so
when did this
start right so you have one email
address one instagram account one
LinkedIn
I think the phone is maybe the same it's
connected right so I'm looking at some
notes here so since
since you were born yes
this year was the first time that you
guys spent 10 days apart
or other than put another way not being
together in one place when you went to a
vipassana retreat all right so could you
explain for people who understandably
will find this interesting and kind of
alien
how did this come about
and and how is it helpful versus
confusing how do you guys do it it is
confusing
but a we should understand that we the
six of us grew up in one room of a size
smaller than this studio okay and for
those who can't see the full Studio not
I mean it's not huge right it's not this
isn't an airplane Hangar it's not a
basketball court like a bed it's like
it's like a bedroom three bunk beds
that's how the the six kids could could
fit in the room like this and then even
later so we grew up like this up until
like school already started and I think
like until 4 13 14 years old it was a
situation more or less
and then the at this moment and then
parents also send us to school by pairs
it was like a legit logistical in
Innovation like buddy diving when you're
scuba diving exactly it was dangerous to
walk on the streets and 90s
together they don't need to walk us to
school so we can do it by ourselves and
always have confidence exactly so they
were sending us by pairs to school not
not only the two of us but the other
kids as well
so we were a pair they was five years
old I was six years old when we went to
the to the school and the the rest of
the kids were seven so we were bitten
because it's two of us we learned how to
learn how to like avoid to protect
ourselves being too rather than one
and then so had to survive he's like
bonding very helpful for the bonding
yeah very helpful for the blending
helping each other like through the
education like doing homework together
all the stuff together in interest by 13
14 years old that's when we started
forming our own ideas of what what could
be cool for us to do in our life and
that was already like uh uh sort of
social justice type of thinking like how
can we make world a better place for
everyone
and starting from there we saw how like
no one literally was supporting this
idea except two of us basically
continued the conversation in between in
between the two of us
and it never fade fade away which ideas
is this this is the combination like
transparency in right government it was
just one branch of this idea
aligned yes the Technologies can
actually
lead us to a better
governance
and that's what we saw it in
enthusiastic experience of being kids
you know like first we realized that you
know when you go to school
all kids they are alone but we weren't
here we give us a lot of advantages we
don't need to struggle to to accompany
it gather around us because it's already
two people it's much easier to gather
um a company like group of friends
around also we realize that you know
like if I know mathematics better we can
do
it's the way so that no one would
wouldn't know that Daniel don't know
mathematics as I do as good as here so
and so so you can actually copy yes
we'll try and diversification and we
learned that that's what we can do that
in if we weren't allowed
outside worlds to actually distinguish
who has which qualities can cover the
basis yes we will be able to seem to be
okay so I know you guys as an example
are fans of the Collison Brothers right
yes amazing and Patrick's been on the
podcast
my understanding is they have they're
very powerful together but they have
maintained they're like I don't say
Batman and Robin That's not quite the
same they're like you know to The
Avengers right I mean they're
superheroes but they have clearly
delineated yes separate like points of
contact and so on
what have been some of the other
advantages
or drawbacks of doing it the way that
you guys have approached it you know
like even though the the kind of it a
bit like definitely more separates and
we do but they did a lot of really great
stuff for example they were like on
President they switched who is Syrian
who is president and they switched role
so they they actually showed to the
world so that they are can kind of
interchangeable to the team and
in there and they are great in this
regards
um in our case we went to just
in an extreme version of that having one
line of communication so if you text me
you actually text both of us and you
don't know who answered this text and
but we can answer faster we can answer
faster we can seems to be this
superhuman in in that worked pretty well
on during negotiations
hated speaking to people as he was young
he was like super not into talking to
people and I was super easy to talk to
people so it was my role in the couple
to talk all the time and I wouldn't
still never he was never picking up the
phone if someone called I don't pick up
the phone either yes for me it's just
too much I don't know what I'm signing
up for unless it's my brother or a
family okay fine there are a few imagine
that you can answer is that that's crazy
so Ian that worked in business principle
even though our first like business
partners they were like why you're on
the same thing like you can be in two
places at the same time and things like
that but we even at some moment give up
on like trying to explain some that's no
that's allow us to in business
especially it's like win or lose like
you you want this contract or lost it
once a contract in in all these meetings
are important if you like playing two
contracts and losing both of them it
doesn't matter that it was two of them
if you're playing one but you're playing
a hardcore game of us being a like a a
team in this conversation which can win
the contract it works much better yeah
bird in the hand versus two in the bush
yeah so what are your respective roles
generally then in terms of our
responsibilities or strengths how do you
think about that I would put this this
way we have two different intuitions
and they're like completely different
David's intuition is
he observed data he remembers everything
and then at some point he can just like
the answer is this like 42 like just out
of nowhere out of like and you're like
why he's like I don't know but I'm
pretty sure that it's 42. 42 yes and
then Checkers got to the guy yeah and
then the next morning he can wake up
he's like yeah and now I know why so I I
figure like I I cleared my past as this
place in my mind which actually made the
calculation and tell me it's 42 so
here's why my intuition is completely
different the meditation is like we need
to fly to London tomorrow
he's like why I have a good feeling
about this
and then we fly to London and we got the
investors
it's like this and like we need to offer
these people this and there is like no
no no no no I'm like yes yes we need to
offer them this I offer them this and
they're like yes agree handshaking and
they're like how did you no I'm just
like I felt it so Daniel much better in
the region people
Daniel much better ingredient situations
in general
I am much better in processing
data processing knowledge I have this
strange qualities that I remember
everything everything
is that hard for you I'm just wondering
because I have family members like this
and sometimes it's a huge Advantage but
are there things that you wish you could
forget or is it I learned to live with
that I think that because we still
because because we have both of it
and I see what is the advantage of a
different type of thinking Etc and
I learned how to live with that and now
I I embrace it I understand the
limitations but I cannot read the
citation properly like I understand the
limitation of this tool
but because it's
two of us and we have both I actually
doubled down into this qualities in in
develop this qualities further and
further and further do you guys get
physical or psychological anxiety when
you are separate
this was the first time when when we
were separating that was the first time
when we were separate not like not even
being able to text each other because
the phone is off during the vapasana for
10 days long what was our life well see
you had something to do I mean
right like but you had a task so what
was it like for you David
it was unexpected but for me it was a
game because I knew that Daniel is
working on something which is important
and if I knew that if he will extract
some new experiences out of it I also
will do that so it's kind of
I outsourced the guinea pig and it was a
guinea pig and I actually felt like I
had this intuition like I gotta do this
and I just went and and it was so quick
so David had to wait for three months in
a line I was accepted four days before
the the course started
everyone expected around that I will be
devastated by this experience but
somehow I was super fun because I
probably because I knew that Daniel is
working on something important for us
and that didn't felt like
yes and then the second time was like
the same situation but the Reversed he
was working on his mind and I was back
home for me it was a little bit more
challenging meaning that
I had this
sort of Mind Trick which was at least
your fault that he's there struggling
there and like what are you talking
about for you it was a great experience
but yeah but for David maybe it's not as
as great maybe it's challenging for him
like come on seriously stop it all right
so you're these yeah you're the internal
voice keeping you company yes it was
part of the reason I ask and I don't
know if this is true this is from the
the New Yorker piece is selling shares
in yourself the way of the future which
I would love to hear what they got if
there's anything you wish were different
in that piece and for those people who
might check it out but I was curious
because at one point it says at home the
brothers share a single king-sized bed
is that still the case
we recently
changed it like in April we moved to a
new house and we basically decided to
have more bedrooms and we have separate
bedrooms now because this Behavior
creates some limitations especially
around relationships
so we decided that especially now when
it's published
additional problem
I was already yeah right in the New York
area I imagine I'm not the first person
to ask about this kid so
in general our bond is quite challenging
in terms of relationship that's why we
decided that we need to make it like
romantic relationship right yes we
decided that we need to explicitly make
it easier for potential romantic
partners and
splitting bedrooms is like is one of the
first key for maybe a key different
floors like Daniel has his own form
David has his own floor in the house so
I can imagine this in my mind right as
I'm as I'm painting a picture I just
imagine the floor is looking very
different like if if the respective
brother is the floors must be very
different but but also you know like
when we were in the same room it was it
was for purpose we usually would stop
talking only like before like a minute
we will go to sleep and start talking
what am I doing today like this is like
this is a wake-up call so now we travel
into New York win one
stop I mean what is what a what an
incredible no
blessing and gift it is that you guys
have each other yeah yeah I mean like
where
absolutely enjoying this way of life yes
as David said challenges in the Romantic
relationship
like we will work it out so do you think
when you have romantic part like let's
just say of romantic Partners maybe you
have families who knows do you think you
guys will still live together
yes yes we maybe we'll maybe we'll do
some you know like uh is in our vision
we maybe can create kind of special
house when you have like sections or
like private and not private space
something like that
because we definitely need to hear also
what's our other partners partners
have to say yes but we really want to
still have a place for for two of us
when we can spend a lot of time together
okay so I have heard people need to fact
check this because I think a friend of
mine told me just as a model that Tim
Burton and his wife I think it's Helena
Bonham Carter if they're still together
I don't know but that in their house
they actually lived in separate wings
and then they would come together for
shared meals and things like that so
they had a very unorthodox we have
friends who build houses when they have
like joined bedroom in separate bedrooms
and a wing for kids yeah so wing for him
wing for her wing for kids and wink for
them together it's like a spaceship yes
yeah I like it yes I like it I'm very
interested in all that's why maybe the
divorce lawyers can give you some advice
what has worked what has not worked
so you mentioned Evan earlier not
everyone's going to recognize that name
how did you guys end up
at snap
so our point of view we always tell the
story from the perspective of us meeting
Dalai Lama in 2010.
when in doubt go with the Dalai Lama
story
so it was back in 2009 right in between
us starting the animation studio and
bankrupting the game Studio there was a
three months of us took a Dalai Lama
sabbatical okay there were three or
three months of us clearly not knowing
what to do and then the bandits are
threatening Our Lives we don't know how
to like return the money and then we
just decided to go for a five six days
Meditation Retreat of
who just arrived to Moscow and a friend
invited us so we came there
with no expectations whatsoever
but the gentleman
was very interesting he was young he was
super smart speaking like 11 languages
and from time to time he would switch
from this Tibetan stories about the
enlightened kingdoms to something more
practical
even like claiming that a single person
can actually change the world if they
want and for us was like wait what are
you talking to us like and
we then asked if we can have a an
audience with the with the we're in
fortune and
and we were told that we that that
everything is booked already but five
minutes later he called us
yeah just sound clear so he is which
teacher even
is like a Tibetan spiritual spiritual
yes it's like a title which you can get
only from your childhood if you
recognize it recognizes Reincarnation of
the previous version of someone else yes
so this gentleman is in Moscow and
rinpochi is asking us to come see him
I'm like wait okay cool so we we shared
our ideas and transparency about how in
the future we can leave within
governments without physical borders in
Fort Tibetan peoples is really yeah
important subjects you know that they
don't have resonated with him and when
we finished our story by saying like and
now it's just two of us
he immediately abrupted us into like the
three of us
and it was touching and they're like
unexpected and he finished his phrase
with
flight like come visit me in India in
what was it January next year
I'm hosting an integration of uh of a
monastery dalalama going to be there and
I will introduce you and we will
introduce your ideas together and we'll
see what we can do together
that meeting actually happened and not
happened at the same time
so we flew to India we spent this week
in the monastery in India Tibetan
monastery
actually arrived we had a non-private
meeting with him with in a group of 10
European donors of the monastery but
then we had to have
a 101 meeting with him next morning
which never happened because the storm
came like this I know this is like a
movie Story the storm came in
immediately
and we're standing there and then half
hours the storm just rushed and flooded
the entire event the next two days
because it was flooded
so but then a month later we received an
email from a gentleman whose name was is
Jerry murdick he's the founder of
insight uh partner one of the biggest VC
firms in New York and the email was like
I'm on the dinner I'm at the dinner with
Dalai Lama and this other
Monk and they told me I have to email
you and they give me your email so
that's what I do that's why I mean
that's what I'm eating you we've met
with him few months later and become
close friends and eventually through so
many different stories he invites us to
a dinner this dinner weren't wasn't
really for us he thought that other
people will come but it didn't work so
so he invited us instead and they're
whatever
yes but since since this introduction we
always
were quite
like cautious about
everything which was related I mean
introduced to someone you stick should
be the reason actually there should be a
reason like and we always try to help
him and like be around and just see
where it will come we'll go you're
talking about Jerry Jerry yes and at
some point eventually he introduced us
to Evan at his house and then Evan gave
me his phone number just right away at
the meeting and it was the right moment
it wasn't expected for everyone around
because that's not that's not what he's
doing
apparently and we were developing
Technologies around
3D avatars computer at that moment
and that's
what was exactly what he wanted
on his mind was he wanted to combine a
bitmoji which was a 2d avatars he
acquired from the Canadian company and
3D engine of AR
a technology of luxury the the Ukrainian
company he acquired
he wanted to merge the two technologies
and we were in our experience in
Hollywood was emerging Technologies we
literally were transferring the 2D
styles of existing animated shows into
3D and back and force and back and forth
in that moment we're also focused on
that on 3D avatars and how like
Technologies can actually not not a show
not not something which require game
type of thinking like because we decided
like right after the financial
transparency for non-profits didn't work
we decided that we looked around and
realized that
the technology advanced like a computer
vision and style transfers and like all
this stuff advanced
a lot since we left the CG graphics and
we realized that we know everything and
more than probably everyone in the field
so we can try to just start something
and and probably going to be successful
gonna like build a successful company
half a year later Evan offered us not
over but already acquired us and so just
for people who might not have the
acronym so AR augmented reality right so
people may recognize some of the current
or recent iterations on Snap where you
can say put
any number of different
sort of overlays of characters I mean
they do Partnerships with all sorts of
companies and so on so you can add
something to your face that sort of
tracks your eye movement and
augments the kind of visual experience
so is that what you guys were working on
in some capacities this technology face
tracking technology it was Ukrainian
accompany luxury which is a recently
acquired before us right and we work how
to combine the avatars into this
technology so right now 3D version of
bitmudge is is the most used avatars
lately in Snapchat it's it's already
everyone like in your profiling games in
in lenses and in all places
and so you guys get acquired
and
if I'm missing a chapter let me know
but
can you describe
what you did what your analysis looked
like when
a Snapchat suddenly started losing users
I think it was in 2017.
2018 18. so it was early in 2018. are
you right 2017
Instagram release their stories and in
the beginning of 2018 new version new
update version of Snapchat with the list
in like Kim Kardashian Twitter or Kylie
Jenner Twitter that like no one would
use Snapchat anymore all this stuff and
audience started to decline
and at that moment most of the people
build a parallel idea in the company was
that it's due to the competition public
sentiment Capital Public sentiment of
the bad new version or competition of
Instagram Instagram in Tick Tock or all
together
while our analysis of David showed us
that it's not true and then the major
reason for the decline of the audience
was in
was related to the fact that Android
version of Snapchat after the update
becomes so slow
that people over time developed a
developed like gave up yeah they just
abandoned they just started the bending
yes 10 of the slowest devices of Android
users could have experienced like up to
40 seconds before the
feed with stories would load next time
when you will open something like the
account supports yeah 40 seconds no way
I'll barely wait for four seconds
exactly so it was so obvious that this
was the reason but it took some time to
like they were we realized that
you know like we didn't have any
specific position related to that in the
company and we realized that what we can
do is actually to to just bring all the
insights which we were able to extract
[Music]
and to just give him all the evidences
so that
more Focus
can be
added so the problem and to to making
the the app faster now why do you think
you guys spotted this right because it
doesn't sound like it's immediately your
department or responsibilities so were
people
with the narrative that it was you know
the Jenners and the Kim Kardashians and
then the competition was that so
accepted at face value that people
weren't looking at the data or what
happened so there were several reasons
first of all it's Android Android we're
Android users in among Executives it was
a really rare things to actually to use
with Android test day-to-day yeah Evan
he pushed himself to to use Android to
experience this all I what his users
usually experience when they use Android
but we use Androids as a day-to-day
devices with hackers we don't like
limitations of
that's why we always were there and so
when we developed our 3D avatars it was
very first it worked faster on Android
than on iOS and it was quite unique to
compared to other products and through
this experience we learned a lot about
some limitations and we already at that
moment looked at some data just for our
products to be launched probably we
wanted to fix a Snapchat's Android app
earlier just for our product to work
better so we kind of had already some
predispositions and beliefs related to
that then when the product was launched
we decided to research everything about
the user behavior in order to understand
how we can better position our product
inside of the Snapchat ecosystem with
such problems the the challenge you know
there are different methodologies for
example there is a methodology to a b
tests when you launch you have a user's
half of the users will see one version
and halfway users will see the different
version and then you will compare the
the results but with
performance degradation
the result is delayed it's not immediate
you cannot really like it's really hard
yes so you need to wait for some time
you need data for for longer period of
time you need to break it
give your users a bad version
wait for them to use it for a long
enough period for you to see the
difference in Behavior sounds like a
tougher science yes even moral decision
was never do that so you shouldn't
really make the
experience of users worse intentionally
and as hacker is for us it was like okay
can we find a way how to get this data
anyway so we started to look at all the
previous boxes
integration which led to and then was
discovered but but lasted for long
enough so that we can actually extract
the change in Behavior so it's really
important to note and in in the article
in in the New York areas it's
the words not from us that's why
they are not as clear
there were people who also believe in
this idea not only us
it was basically just very initiative we
just it just there were not enough
momentum yeah not enough people who
would work on this problem there were
really brilliant Engineers already
before that started to rewrite and we
had our daily meeting with Evan so we
actually could have like you could be
good ambassadors yeah so we so we used
our previously earned uh
we need to just spend all the social
capital on this problem otherwise
like shares dropped to five dollars per
share from 20 in all our like the entire
computation of ours in the equity of
course inequity and of course so and
also we we saw the opportunity you know
for us we got through two major crisis
in our life
not not counting the the childhood
crisis financial crisis that's why
somehow for us when it is a crisis for
us it's a great time so we're like oh
like now our weekends show how we can
hide yes never let a good crisis go to
waste yes exactly so and at some point
we just
had to show that we are good Engineers
as well so David just in order to
challenge
the status quoi David had to sit down
and fix camera I mean camera Snapchat is
camera and David made it load like what
is it devices fast like not load like
when you press a button how fast the
picture would be ready I showed that it
can be the speed can be doubled so and
it was like oh wow so yes you are guys
also a great Engineers as well so how do
you do that how did you do that and we
showed some of the principles of how you
can find inefficiencies in the in the
code but still it's really important so
it was a really team effort of great
Engineers actually was part of this
process what we see is our contributions
is that this kind of promotion
and bringing this voice to to the
decision makers so that they also will
be empowered with data to then spread it
to the entire organization
and that's what definitely really great
times and it worked in you know like
even though Snapchats has some
challenges right now with
Financial financial side of things but
with audience since then it's great the
audience is growing recently reached
like 800 million the audience is growing
in the countries where the Androids are
even slower
so the app actually is pretty
significant right it's still open till
right now in terms of Android apps it's
still like one of the fastest apps to
load compared to the major app sounds it
was interesting as well so launching a
new updated version was
only happened when like in march-ish of
but it was also important and like we we
put lots of efforts into this program
more than more than the other one to fix
the existing version before the new was
released the old had to be fixed in
order to stop bleeding yeah
and by December the bleeding stopped I
can see it's from there and in January
the audience started to grow even before
the university it was March the new
version was released it never actually
slowed down since then so I have a
question about this type of
data-driven analysis do you attempt to
do this type of analysis with
goals or challenges that you have in
your personal lives is do you to try to
apply it everywhere are there examples
that you could give outside of the
business context first of all we should
note that we as Daniel mentioned about
intuition we believe in both we believe
in notation we believe in data approach
but yes so for example one of our
kind of one of the major principle is
that so we
know what is compound growth and for
example we when we have some crazy goals
crazy for some people they they will set
some goals in these goals I seems to be
impossible what we show again and again
that actually if you
have kPa for example number of followers
goals like visible number of followers
or number of dollars in your pocket
quantifiable qualifiable what you can do
is that you can
evaluate what you have right now
and then if you can multiply this number
two if you can double two times a year
it is a greatness you like you have like
the entire
money on Earth the entire population the
following Etc so it's really important
then you when you have this big goals
you can't have any big goal with this
approach you just don't need to run
faster than something the number two
times every year actually what we
realized that there is there's
definitely Corridor if physical
limitation at the top which is around
2.4 like you cannot run faster than
increasing your results 2.4 times a year
in a long long run but what we realized
that is actually it's it's really tiny
Corridor if you increase this number 1.6
times
you're successful
if you increase
this number 2.4 times
so this this is only the small Corridor
you don't need to think about something
no this is multiplying your kpi by 1.7
times every year every year every year
once per year once per year yeah yes and
we applied it a lot in our life in our
business life in the life of our
companies in our personal life so we we
use this will be an example from the
personal life maybe it doesn't have to
follow that doubling
heuristic it could but what might be an
example but for example amount of hours
you spent with a romantic partner you
inspired by
[Music]
okay so and so you would look at your
you would track the hours and then look
to multiply that yes over time so you
should expect that immediately you you
would start a relationship which would
be perfect and like you will spend all
the time and all this time would be
perfect and great Etc but if you have
one hour
of this experience a year this the next
year it can be two hours as the next
year it can be four hours for some it
might sound like in in 10 years you have
the entire life like that
it's a slow build
and we just realized that when you try
to run faster you can actually break
yourself I see what you're saying so you
can make a mistake by saying okay I'm
gonna spend half my time this year with
this person because you're sort of
biting off more than you can chew yeah
and maybe
shooting yourself in the foot for the
long term yes
okay so basically having an eye towards
growth but not being excessively
ambitious in the beginning because
you'll break things yes I know one
personal experience yes this is like
when you're when you want too much right
away you break stuff
yeah I can see that as someone who's
killing like physical breakage also yeah
but even with the acceleration when
you're in the rockets fly into space
there is this limitation of like three
G yeah like three times G
which then actually start breaking
stuffing yourself so it seems that it's
an if it's kind of natural number this
is what we can sustain like 2.4 like uh
to 1.6 this is something which we can
sustain physically and mentally
you want to play music just start from
something achievable right now today
like double your result every year and
you will become like Beyonce
certainly truth physical activity too
weightlifting or whatever you don't need
to 10x yes the number every year and if
you try you want 10 actually you try
like I've tried then you start damaging
your connective tissue or yeah
one of the Olympic teams was it in UK or
something because I don't remember
exactly but they got a new tech trainer
and the new trainer was coach coach was
with this approach like but support was
like we need to improve our kpis one
percent a week it's almost the same
in they and they become yeah become
champion from like nowhere like the last
position on the list so it's about
physical activity is the same in in
business activity writing money Finance
music
you can but but really important that
you can achieve anything you can have
any type of mission or big goals
but then you write this you like draw
this as long as you're consists for
yourself yes and be consistent
so what are some of the Maybe
Logistics challenges and how have you
address them in running your
business is how you run them or
organizing your lives the way that you
guys organize them we have a very messed
up calendar
it's like multi-dimensional
does that mean that you're just
traveling all over the place do you have
we travel a lot for sure
we probably like this year were in the
states for three months all over the
year but at home like at home in L.A
even less time than that maybe like one
week a month more than that but what
helped a lot that's it it started with
two of us but it's quite fast two of our
sisters joins and they usually they
don't travel that much and they usually
run
operations and scaling of them any of
your other siblings have the pair
bonding that you guys have no but but
five of us we are quite close and we
work together we work together we leave
together in L.A like our houses is
literally like two minutes away from
each other yes and and they start to run
our operation scenes game development
and then the
um and then our equal Partners in
Animation Studio
in since then it's much easier for us to
to dream more and to to act
um no now we discuss everything together
like philosophy the vision for the
future the the morality like it's a it's
a constant discussion among all of us so
I can imagine I'm just putting myself in
the place of people listening to this
that they're I'm sure there are people
out there who work with family and then
there are other people who don't work
with family but I imagine working with
my family and I love my family but I'm
like wow if I hired
two people from my family to run my
operations what do you do if it's not
working
I mean would you ever fire them or just
have complete confidence that you can
resolve anything that might come up how
do you think about you're definitely
getting fired but for sure I mean what
have we learn so so you know we went
through really harsh experience with
game development Studio bankruptcy and
they were the only ones who stayed with
us so it was a challenging period yeah
yes in in when you actually
or went through such experience it's
much easier to trust not trust just
because it's family but because you know
what you can expect how they behaved
and especially in in Venture business
when as we mentioned most of the
attempts will fail would fail
it is really important quality to have
someone who you can trust that they are
with you
long term
not just for this project
and
I would say this worked pretty well
maybe this was the results of this
experience which we all
had
but maybe just because our parents work
together
for us we didn't have this concept model
that's it's not right
no and we want some challenges
definitely we argue with each other Etc
so we went through a lot of challenges
but
it's worth it well I was thinking also
as you saw your sisters I suppose doing
the challenges of the game development
company
has reminded me of a quote I don't know
the attribution but that's in English is
a common expression adversity builds
character but the
the alternative which I think might be
just as true or maybe truer is adversity
doesn't build character it reveals
character reveals character and so you
got to see how they responded to
a lot of challenge
which gave you the confidence then
and there were a lot of challenges
and we are lucky
in many ways
[Music]
so I wanna I wanna ask you about
this is
same question applied to two different
groups so the first is going to be your
parents and I want to just ask about
what ideas of theirs you find most
interesting maybe that's a place to talk
about chimatics maybe not but the then
the second is
what ideas you guys are most excited
about right now
but I wanted to start with
do we have a couple more hours for ish
yes exactly so our parents so our that
he was from physics
but he was
by government pushed out from physics
because he was June in and he switched
to biology because by physics was an
open field so physics was more protected
and and Jews were more discriminated
against in physics so he found this
niche
it was a new Niche it was an emerging
new science and he came there
with
knowledge of physics and that gave him a
different perspective than this is a
biologist's huge Advantage who would see
everything through the prism of
chemistry or through a super prism of
biology he looked at the through the
prism of physics and he started
discovering things faster faster in this
field
starting with the first thing which he
discovered was that the color which
received by an eye
isn't called it not in the frequency
which is then translated as a as a
signal inside of the eye nerve but as a
pattern of the signal causes
spikes so the spice like almost quite
more
and this is sort of like that's how he
realized that it should be a computer is
there that should be a computation
because the encoding happened he came to
this idea there was a really interesting
weird Obsession of his on the idea that
if evolution was working properly for
millions of years if not billions of
years then it should be optimal that the
most optimal mechanisms should should
have survived the evolution process and
therefore what's the most optimal from
the physics perspective in terms of
measuring the amount of energy spent on
the operation separation and and data
he's like time time in between in the
quantum
events this is probably the most optimal
one and that like from this perspective
he was like from the perspective
optimality he was trying to find how the
eye works and he was the one to discover
exactly how it works and he's like wow
so I was right about optimality and then
used optimality all the way down
exploring into the nerve into into the
neuron
and into the core of the cell into the
DNA and then like across the entire cell
so climatic was the abbreviation of
chemistry Optics in mathematics so he
always believed that the real
discoveries are in combination of
different fields that actually the the
fact that we learn this subject
separately
limited limiting Us in terms of us being
able to discover some things which
requires you to look at some
interdisciplinary yes synthesis he was
he was pushing this idea of
interdiscipline and they're success both
like about that amount
the success was because of that so they
would combine things which others would
wouldn't come by for example he brought
a quantum physics
into describing cells practices
so even here like maybe 2008 2010 it was
really merchandise idea in science
scientists they were trying to avoid it
avoid as much as possible some
complicated processes in biology because
religious chemistry challenge the ideas
that it happened randomly and that they
was trying to avoid that in only
recently more and more discoveries
around photosynthesis which probably
requires Quantum tunneling and then
there's the smell in the this fact that
the birds can see the direction of
polarization of light polarization of
light and like where is North Pole so
this all can be described on the
through the quantum properties of some
processes which happen inside your life
it's the biggest discovery which we
personally like it's the last Discovery
you know
the entire concept that our
consciousness
work through the if there was a Quantum
compute inside every single neuron so
every single neuron is sort of a qubit
it's like a Quantum State machine itself
which then combined in the network
produce all the results but every neuron
is quantum State machine this can
actually explain a lot about our
psychology about how we think how our
Consciousness work but also it can give
Humanity a lot of Clues how to build
proper quantum computers So currently
the quantum computers which we build
like Google builds or Microsoft builds
they are all require some really
complicated environments so you need to
throw the computers to like minus 270
degrees Celsius fully isolated from any
chaotic uh electro magnetic fields and
stuff so it's really complicated
while if our parents write
in everything
this practice happening at room
temperature so we can actually look at
how biology right made it and then
builds a new class of quantum computers
which can actually be in your watch and
then and then this can accelerate the
the personal AI development not the
preparations big AI but the one which
would be with you always and things like
that plus there is a chance also as well
that if these processes are happening
inside of the cell the answer to a room
temperature
can also be there somewhere so I mean I
I know that recently there was this
entire hype with
supposedly discovery of the room
temperature superconductors
superconductors it seems that it didn't
work this time fully but we all like why
everyone were
was so excited because it can change
everything it can change how we build
roads it can change how we build
electrical grids anything like
understanding the the quantum levitation
all roads can be done from
superconductors if all roles can build
then we have flying cars
if the same roads can then become a
electric Network which distributes
electricity like around the globe from
sustainable or certain like sustainable
sources of energy like solar panels we
have days somewhere each hour all the
time and if the superconductors can
surround the planet then we have
electricity everywhere without the
losing
of power so lots of stuff can come from
the superconductors the answer can be
inside of ourselves yes so in the
biggest Discovery was that the answer
can be inside of the cells if we can
actually
look at the properties of this nanotubes
and they're really special is this
really like right now there are a lot of
discoveries showing that these nanotubes
have properties which no one would
expect that they would have even though
we all know about physics and chemistry
but we cannot predict this properties
something like we're not quite sure
about like because this is recent not
probably probably not even published or
maybe some some discussions in the
conferences is happening that the
nanotubes of that sort
the cytoskeleton nanotubes has called
microtubulars
they can capture photons they can
capture light and direct it within its
structure as the light actually hits the
microtubular and the Phantom goes inside
the tube and then like as if it's a
quart which captures the light in them
so a lot of freely unexpected and great
properties which can be used in
Industries and which can be used by
Humanity to just accelerate our
development so the this this is the most
exciting part about parents but it's
important that they just realize that to
achieve that we need to be
interdisciplinary and we need to combine
he was through the last years he was a
promoters that he believes that in
schools we should teach kids like that
so like not to teach like physics and
chemistry and like volleyball
together in in show how all this
interconnected in
in that we need to kind of grow in New
Generation of scientists who wouldn't be
so
siled silence
in the disciplines all right so I want
to segue to the ideas that you guys are
currently most excited about thank you
for explaining all that every time I
anyway I I could spend hours just
digging into what you just said maybe
another time but since you mentioned
teaching which relates to learning
how would you
teach kids to code or people to could oh
that's interesting versus versus how
it's maybe currently taught so first of
all we saw that computer science
historically emerged from mathematics
and and this speaking Minds like ours
and so it's really great for us but for
most people it's really alienating
because if you're not good in math
mathematics you will just avoid even
learn because you will think that you
are not really great in that in reality
the language coding is much closer to
learning French or in Japanese it's
actually lazier a friend of mine
published a small book which was
basically code is poetry yes and it's
interesting one can you share it because
we actually also wrote a tiny book like
English language sure sure I'll find it
for you I'll find it for you man and I'm
not sure if he published it but he gave
it away as a gift Matt mullenwick who's
the founder and CEO of automatic and was
one of the lead developers arguably the
lead developer of Wordpress I mean you
need to combine our thoughts in one book
so I'll find it for you I created during
pandemic had some additional time so I I
created a interactive online book
where you learn that you can actually
first
type something in a normal language
description of the world description of
the and then it can be easily translated
by you in into the recording language
like python or C plus plus or
or Swift it's literally like a
translation first you you wrote it in
your own language and then you translate
it into the code so the only thing which
you need to learn is this a little bit
different grammar rules now in different
people different way to describe the
world
and that's what mostly you should learn
you shouldn't learn the the
of this language
and if you use this method to learn then
you can actually code in in any language
because it appears that Swift or C plus
plus they all the same they all
interchangeable every time when I
interview an engineer and this engineer
would say that oh like I know only this
language
this would be a red flag for me because
it means that you don't really
understand and all these languages like
they're almost the same yes there are
nuances but you all almost don't have
tasks which actually require you to use
these nuances
but if if you understand the kind of
metal language and this metal language
is really close to real natural language
then you can actually code in any
language in in that so that's what we
really promoting we happen to actually
teach some people according would never
think that they can code and it who
would think that it's mathematics is not
theirs like moms of two
housewives having like and they are
great because they're great in language
and if you're great in language if you
you can actually learn this language as
well
so in especially right now even though
yes
of the world they can code for yourself
but but if you know how to code the you
you will be well off in the next like 12
20 years like 10 20 years
so for people who are listening if they
are resonating with what you're saying
right so for instance I'm I'm a casualty
of
mathematics I was actually very good at
math my brother also very good at math
and we had very different experiences
with teachers so he had a few great
teachers and I had one very very angry
kind of abusive teacher and so I said no
more math for me even though I was
innately quite good at it he kept going
and got PhD into statistics and you know
he's very math capable but I sort of
developed a I had like an adolescent
onset allergy
but I recognize the the beauty and
elegance and value of code I don't think
I would ever use it as a profession but
I like the idea of testing myself
but I've always struggled with trying to
identify how to start right and I've
looked at AI as maybe a way to
use an intermediary so I can use natural
language to do some type of coding but
how would you suggest to someone who is
interested maybe a little nervous but
would like to explore coding there is a
free book on our Instagram like there is
link which you can try it's it's it's
definitely only the first step then you
will need to learn more but at least
through the step
our expectations that you will stop
being nervous and afraid of accordingly
right
yes this is definitely that's why we
wrote this book just to make it easy
because I don't like any other courses
because they all like stacked with
syntaxes Etc in in is not the way you
it's not the way you start to it's there
are great they are Great Courses it's
just like not the way you start because
you alienate people who are like oh
function what is function which I don't
know anything about coding but it's it's
the same with foreign languages right I
mean it's like you see the way that
they're taught it's like okay here's a
huge table of conjugations memorize this
and people are like ah no thanks
no no here's a comic book like it's like
let's look at some things that you can
use immediately make it fun and then
like later we can do the harder stuff
and also what what we found and that's
how we learn how to code is that another
example usually when you learn language
you first read write you read and and
you need to read some some
easy but good written
look book to to learn the language
software engineering it's the same like
we actually we mocked in Instagram
application
we wrote a clean simple Instagram of a
simple Instagram because everyone knows
what it is and I won't understand how it
works so if you read this code you
understand what
and then in the middle of the course
you're just okay now change now change
some stuff in the code and you will see
the changes in the app and as you change
the the the the parts of the code you
see the changes in the app and you're
like oh that's how it works it's also
positive feedback and also if even if
you decide not to be an engineer if even
for example if your products person
product manager or marketing person QA
it's really important for you to
understand what is it otherwise you
won't be able to give properly the the
tasks so Engineers you won't be able to
manage engineers and and you're losing a
lot of opportunities you will always be
triggered by Engineers because you will
ask them to do something but they will
do something really different if you
don't really understand their language
but as soon as you do it's actually I
wish we had more time and more like
eager to to actually finish the full
course but it's absolutely not the
Premier Premier League goal you know
like hectic life as well so but I'll
link to that in the show notes so that
people are interested can at least find
it and give it a shot I might do the
same thing
so ideas exciting ideas exciting ideas
yeah things that things that are it
could be projects could be missions
could be ideas just things that have you
both feeling
excited and
motivated like Where Do We Go identity
International
Gap so so understand this ideas yes
there are sorts of things first
observations which we
have about the world
and the substitution you they give us a
different perspective
and this perspective is almost obviously
led us to some ideas and projects and
then usually when we have ideas these
ideas exist in us for some years and
then we trying to crystallize them into
the project
one of the major observation which
actually started from bankruptcy of game
development Studio we really wanted to
understand
financial crisis like what how we missed
it I mean not that we missed it like we
saw that there is like a problem in the
real estate market but everything
collapsed around really we thought that
just real estate market will collapse
but everything collapsed little did we
know about how the financial Market
Works yes so in then we dig deeper in
get first we got to the same conclusion
our conclusions that
this all led to this bubble but for us
usually like sometimes like all this
stuff yes people usually like when it's
about diverse and create default swaps
like Bankers they they made this
deregulation they they are the problem
and that's that's how it all happens but
we usually it's like every time when we
we have a statement we check it with
data and we decided to understand that
who was the actual beneficial
beneficiary of the gravity default swaps
not of their fall but of them being
created and popular popularized that way
and then we realized that most of the
create default swaps through some
Vehicles they were owned by Pension
funds they were like what yes we are
from a region
where Pension funds really
small pensioners are really poor people
poor people and you would never think
that they could sound like
multi-trillion dollars huge huge United
States
are like what is it 40 trillion dollars
it's more than the entire publicly
traded Market combined you will combine
all Apple Google accent Walmart
companies it's smaller than the the
assets of all together less than the
asset suspension fund so through this
reason we started to learn more and more
like how the hell it happened and it was
a great invention I mean the fact that
United States is the greatest economy in
the world is because of this not because
of the army not because of military some
big chunk of their money and the money
was not just saved but was invested into
the market and that's how Market got all
the capital to grow
etc etc etc but then realize that
unfortunate fortunately
as soon as this population
not only
grew to the amounts that they are the
majority of Voters but also they have
this enormous Financial power the
financial power which is bigger than the
banks the bigger than any other
organization
so this financial power in this
voting power together combining right
LEDs to a lot of popular political
decisions and regulations which was
completely false which led to uh types
of things so we can give you some some
taste of it yeah yeah for example when
we when we first came to United States
we learned about student debt student
loan and for you it's obvious like it's
United States ever ever since commercial
that's why
is not free that's how we got to the
student
by the student that if you will look at
the size in before 2000s
it was really a small problem it's now
like two trillion dollars but before
that it was a much much much much
smaller problems and what we realized
that previously like in 80s
your tuition when you go to state
college would be mostly subsidized by
governments like 90 of your tuition will
be subsidized by governments that's
that's how your experience were able to
actually pay for this Artisan during the
summer job like so through the summer
job and that's how the the death never
accumulated as much
[Music]
but in late 80s beginning of 90s because
of almost bankrupt States Bankruptcy
state of public Pension funds public
Pension funds in many states
the governments in different states and
in federal level as well bailed up made
a decision to not only bail out but also
for the future protect
this Pension funds for example in
California the growth of public Pension
funds including teachers funds
guaranteed on a level of 7.8 percent a
year imagine that your deficit would be
guaranteed a state budget and it's not
even average estate budget it's a
subsidies to education went down as a
result yes exactly yes so you can see
because of during the money is still
there tons of information become public
publicly available you can trace it it's
all there so tons of data but if you
like to dig into this data you can find
it it's just there you can see it you
can like all right the money goes into
the education then
okay so the Casper Casper so in
California yes it's a public pensioned
funds or by pension fund the public
works and pension fund of teachers of
California
no one really realizes the size of these
funds and only realize the the Gap in
between assets and liabilities of this
funds so when everyone discusses that
the Pension funds are underfunded it's
only public pensions
trillion dollars of a gap five trillion
dollars and it the this is accounting
the money which is constantly
transferred someone might think from
subsidies
this is just public workers like they
are probably what 15 of Workforce in the
United States and yet the size of their
Pension funds is half of all pensions of
all Pension funds even though it's only
15 of a Workforce why because of a
guaranteed 7.8
annual growth because when the rest of
the market goes down up down up and like
so in the this problem is not only
education if you look at the police you
know there was this big movement of
unfunding police
and we looked at the budgets and a per
person in L.A for example per
officer in La it's almost like 250
000.
250 000 a year and people were like
angry about that like why why the hell
like we pay you a lot and like you're
not doing your job but then what what
the real work is right now the real
officers right now I'm not paid as much
and they get only a tiny portion of it
and most of it
causes a transfer for Pension funds for
officers who worked 30 years ago now
again so where does this lead you guys
are looking at the data and I suppose
like a good set of data ideally allows
you to have some predictive ability or
at least speculation ability
so what do you do with this absolutely
we realize that every Next Generation
because of that
zooming out to a larger picture what
what it led to is that through the
generations starting saying from Boomers
I know I know this is like a false
science about dividing people into those
Generations but we can
it was born around 50s yes the Boomers
as they were getting into 30 years old
on average as a generation
own something around 21 23 of national
wealth in the United States that follow
in generations and access at the same
age
like me
average age
owned around seven
us the millennials
by the same age owned only less than
three percent like 2.8 ish and then the
trajectory shows us that together with
the crisis which happened during the
covet
we can expect that the Next Generation
after either gen Z gonna be in debt by
by saying average age so they still as
as on average as a generation they still
gonna be in that so trajectory really
bad sounds bad and also on what this
created so if these young people
not if when they realize that the social
agreement is not working
social structures will start to fall
apart yeah what do you think are some
likely ways that that will show up we
will see
we will see like the new wave of unions
protests people not working economies
slowing down
this stuff new business is not created
we can see from the statistics that over
the last 10 years
the share of the new businesses created
in the United States and in the United
States lots of new businesses created
every year lots of them never survive
the year but like that's the case you
create many many businesses and lots of
them die and some of them survive and
that's the economy so the share of the
new businesses created annually in
United States but the people under 30
years old
it used to be 40 or 45. let's say 40 and
now 10 years later now it's a 30. so
it's it's down 10 there's the same
number of companies being yeah just by
younger and older or is the the number
more people more companies the total
number is sort of the same it's just
like not young people creating them it's
people 55 plus creating them
that's surprising that's surprising you
know what like I I would expect I never
checked the data but my my intuition
tells me all those businesses are just
real estate
people buying houses and renting them
out so nothing new is created just the
this spike in the price in real estate
is just because of buying and renting
out so and those are the new views so
there are a lot of problems in but still
like when you talk about the problems uh
it's really important so also at least I
propose some Solutions in what we saw
because we realized that this shift is
based on regulations it's not natural
that this shift is happening so
regulations which Market regulations
yeah regulations that's the rules which
was set by the previous generations
which in making this constant sensor
yeah we realize that if you would
kind of decipher the circulations what
they did that they made a preference to
equity
to make sure to the companies Etc
compared to the income individually so
capital gain is tax blast like there are
a lot of things which actually made the
the huge difference between
Equity how Equity treated by the
regulation and by the market personally
and how personally got it right the
taxation everything the fashion funds
can invest in that but they cannot
invest in that in things like that's
really limitations sets not naturally
Capital like the majority of the capital
is is pension Capital then where it can
be invested matters a lot sure so in
this term we realize that the solution
which we can test and propose at least
try is to try to convert income
individual income to into Executive
Security cases this is where the
Deliverance company the first time first
time we did this to ourselves with is as
a scientist you need to to make the
experiments and the experiments first I
wish more scientists did this yeah you
gotta be the first be the first monkey
shot in the space yes at less than three
G's just to be yeah so realize okay like
if you want to survive so even though
our income is not stable but if you will
build a model around all the Founders
All Tech Founders and the probabilities
of successes During the period of time
we can build an income model
like you would do with a company
kind of cash flow projection risk
weighted risk adjusted cash flow
projection of an entrepreneur and then
based on this protection Value stock
okay yes in the in the index by based on
these projections you can actually set a
price for a company which would have the
same type of income and this guy is case
if you can form the company then you can
attract investment
the same way companies
do and in this case you will eliminate
this bias and vice versa will be
supercharged
by this the capital income
improving your future
like personal income is a supercharged
just to try to ensure I'm hearing you
correctly so supercharged meaning if you
if you're showing a decent rate of
growth even though your Capital
constrained if you can bring in equity
investors who invest in you as if you
were a company you can accelerate your
growth and potential yes
and then we can average this as an index
as an index cross some cohorts of
specific professions
or or specific chords like students for
example you have higher education or you
don't have higher education how does it
change your average income should we
invest
in Goods every kid to have the good
higher education for them to increase
their individual income and that's where
investors get their money back or should
we just leave it the way it is right now
with the loan which then suppress the
wheel to go in there and risk and that's
how young people don't create new
businesses and just go find a shitty job
so how do you think you incentivize this
type of
wider adoption and data sharing right
because I can imagine if you're if if
let's just say we Flash Forward and this
has been widely adopted now I can choose
or do I want to invest in people who are
going getting accounting degrees or
maybe I have a more reliable return on
my investment year on year or do I want
to invest in like the growth stocks that
have much higher volatility right like
the entrepreneurs of a certain class or
maybe an age bracket where
it's going to be a much riskier by
volatility measurements investment but
who knows like you know the the gains
could be higher how do you go from
a single proof of concept I have also
questions about taxation just if you're
being taxed at an ordinary income level
how you translate that effectivity
effectively to equity holders who might
be your investors let's just say but
well we could we could we could tackle
any any one of those so it could be like
how do you
how do you contend with maybe the
handicap of having ordinary income taxed
even though that's presumably what
people are investing in on some level
like the discounted cash flow or
whatever
and then what is this how do you take
this and encourage other people to
experiment with it some loss should be
changed to make it widely adopted
but now we start with ourself as Tech
entrepreneurs because most of our income
comes from building companies and
selling companies or like listening
company like making companies there is
no difference whether you
registered this company under your name
or you registered this company under a
holding company name so there is no
that's a great Point that's a great
point you guys are actually operating in
a very
in an easier case straightforward case
because most of your gains would be from
companies from companies therefore
likely long-term capital gains maybe you
have like that's USBS exclusions
Etc versus if you guys were like very
high paid lawyers or something it could
get a lot trickier yes we went through
that
prove it to pay Regulators pave the way
through so that supports thousands of
like entrepreneurs can actually show
under an example that it works for the
investors and then if it works for the
investors then we can introduce new
regulations which will make it work for
the professionals let's say software
Engineers doctors lawyers and from there
go to even wider groups like students so
there need to be more even more
regulations because like kids need to be
protected and stuff like this but it all
possible to be done so we're pretty sure
we're too sure that at least some
politicians who will see is that their
voters can benefit out of it and that
they can actually live better life and
the the problems like student debts can
be solved in just really short term by
the tools like that
we hope that some
rules will change and what's interesting
right now right now
most of the Pension funds are invested
in really bubbled
overpriced assets just because it's too
much money
and not that much
of instruments like financial
instruments to actually generate the
growth that's why they needed this
credit to fall swabs Etc because they
need this derivatives
because it was just too much money to
invest yeah right if it would be enough
everyone will win like Pension funds
will win like people will win it's just
the girls economy would be much faster
than it's like it's going to be 10 times
larger market
to invest in when we start investing in
individual income as Equity so what do
you say to people who think about this
now okay there's I'm sure there are
cases where this would be very
attractive at least initially right so
you might have somebody like a very
promising YouTuber they want to build
out a studio and hire I guess they could
go out and raise like an equity round
that's what we did okay but with
individual
the income like in the YouTubers okay so
how now do you think if somebody is
really successful that they would try to
renegotiate or that they would not try
to there is an example it's not us it
was before us there is a fund which
invested in college athletes
in the proposed every
College athletes they they had their
model they took the statistics because
it's quite statistical it's like a Money
Ball type of a game like they they
calculated their way to understanding
how to predict how many students they
should invest in in order to basically
hit a couple of LeBron James exactly yes
and they offer it every student era like
the same price five ten percent
five ten percent of your future income
and we pay you the same price it's 10
million dollars of so half a million
million dollars five to ten percent
seventy
students agreed
one of them already netted 15 years
contract was 350 million dollars so they
they did great with the fans yeah they
did pretty well there is one
who's tried to challenge this agreement
in court this one athlete was it the
same athlete no no this one this one
there is a great interview of him where
he explains that this money actually
helped him the best decisions he would
never do another decision just imagining
like he might be cool with it but I'm
thinking about like the managers and the
agents who are like what the [__] is
this
but it worked out yes it worked out
forever but there is another athlete who
netted like three four million dollar a
year type of contract he tried to
challenge this in the court and
everything
in this case
is more complicated than with our case
he was 16 when he signed he English
wasn't his main language anything like
that
so he signed in steel Court
was on the side of investors so
how can people find more about this
particular example if they wanted to
Google something I will send you you can
say to me we'll put it in the show notes
yes I think it was in Wall Street
Journal the the description of all this
case but also I can send you the links
to the court case because we Google that
way we all the court cases they open so
you can see all the arguments and
arguments of the Court
they they were about the fact that he
did well so it's not about Investors
taking the classroom view I think like
that so he did well in in also investors
described all the scenarios so there is
a scenario in the agreement that there
is nice that you will they will do well
in this case we'll get this amount of
money so they described
so moreover so definitely remember what
was in their contract but in our
contract when we with your investment
with our investors and when we investors
invested already in like around dozen
people
we we have this
like minimal income of yours before
which we are not getting anything okay
yeah there's a hurdle right yeah there's
a hurdle like because because
and it's not about your last penis we
actually aim to have the outliers yeah
it's a parallel in in most of Industries
there is this power law it's not only in
Tech it's just in art in in podcasts in
like thinking about this like we will
all win the market will win Society will
win Humanity will win from the fact that
we will use the spiral law for wider
groups of people to invest in them
provide them capital and provide them
chance to get a higher education to try
to start a business
it's like so question about your
Investments yes to the extent that and
we can look at it at least two different
ways so one could be your investors and
why they chose to invest in you guys but
since you guys made the decisions about
your Investments I'm curious about those
people
how many of them to what extent did you
choose them based on their earning
potential and so on versus their
potential to be a good Ambassador or
story for
this model right because they both seem
to matter yes
like a good investment may have the
financial Roi but there's also
showcasing because we have not that much
money to invest in every people we want
we needed to pick those who will be a
good story so definitely we we look at
both so makes sense in terms of
investors in us the first in investor
who supported us and who basically you
know he did not allow us to uh back up
back up back off like how to say back up
yeah yeah and we were almost ready to
say like to give up it's like okay we're
not doing this and you're like no no no
guys you have to do this like please
some lesson he actually had the similar
idea when he was out of high school in
2001 he is one of the general partners
of slow Ventures two early lesser than
us but then other prominent names like
Mark Andreessen or Chris Dixon or Josh
Kushner they they also now invest a tiny
share of the liberal months in the
Germans
so but we earned it so we
it didn't work right away but we made
the first round then we proved some
results and we made the second round so
like with the startups
so when we invest
for us definitely
it means a lot that we want to find
really great examples because all these
examples will affect the future of the
idea and this will
help others to get access to the same
type of resources but what's more
important for us the major thing is
whether we believe and this is intuition
if the person will continue building
after failing
yeah that's a big one because you're not
just investing in one yes
moreover we would come and already did
this through the last year and a half as
we're investing in people we we came to
people and said like quit it drop it I
mean that's not worth your time it's not
working like switch to something new you
will never hear about it ever hear
something like that from the investor
who invested in this particular company
if I invested in you personally I am
mostly interested in your success and if
you are like locked yourself refreshing
if you're locked yourself into something
which you like no no I gotta do this
like this is failure it's not failure
it's an attempt
60 70 of those attempts gonna gonna like
end up with zero so just move on start
next one you'll be successful later
so
with Sam it's probably our like best
relationship with the investors so
forever
so because it can be really open in
not just you know like showing the goods
results but also showing the things
you're not working struggles because now
we like in a different type of
relationship and we really like it and
we actually you know like we had
challenging experiences with investors
so I don't think so it's gonna take you
in any basements yes it seems unlikely
exactly so
um but not even that I mean like he's
fully supporting us
in the same when we invest so we
understand like some of the founders who
invested already failed with their
current projects and they started the
new one and we were the ones who support
them through this process some of them
are coming through like going through
like
hard times and we would say go for a
sabbatical
like take care of yourself like you need
to be super efficient and you need to be
like happy
long term this will score us much more
than if you're like will destroy
yourself right now running out in the
next year yeah yes and involved really
have a really beautiful examples when
Founders were able through this Freedom
we're able to act the way they wouldn't
act in they they it's already gave some
results
like we completely enjoyed with the
passes of all the people who we invested
in and they're all very different
different stories different individuals
different
fears like it's every everywhere from
YouTuber to like
Reinventing quantum physics
yes it was YouTuber Marina she is
actually really also awesome example she
is a Founder she had the startup but to
create a marketing vehicle for the
startup she created a YouTube channel
and send you to this YouTube channel
media Empire they kind of like a much
larger things
making like a million plus uh a year a
year from this from her network
a mortgage family kids or like it's all
risk which you like you wouldn't bet all
of your income to the growth yes he
choose growing fast but as soon as she
got like the understanding that she can
use the capital
from her future like literally this is
what we are doing this is capital from
your future if you are doing as you are
doing right now then clearly you're
gonna have that amount of money in the
future you can take part of this money
which already almost exists
into the current into the present time
and use it in order to make your future
even more successful
so this brings up something that
I wasn't sure we would get to but I
figure I can bring it up time machine is
it possible well there's the time
machine but there's also maybe
the
and I go back and forth on how I feel
about this but the I guess we could you
could look to the data if you have such
data and there is some I would seem but
the maybe the over fetishizing of
suffering and how that contributes to
success or the belief that the more one
struggles the more likely you are
to have outside success because those
make for good stories right yes somebody
suffers for their whole life and then
they show how much they can persevere
and then they succeed but if you look at
you know some of the examples that you
mentioned earlier of like the Dropout
and then the big company these are not
stories of abject suffering from the
earliest stages of childhood generally
right so would you say and this is tying
it to what you just said that by
relieving some of those pressures with
the mortgage and the kids you're
improving the likelihood of an a bigger
success later or somebody could
certainly look at it and say well she's
not going to be as hungry
so we have
lots to say about this subject that's
why I'm asking a
a if we will look at the most successful
experiment of all times for the humanity
providing free school education
free school education for everyone
doesn't matter but they're a smartest
kid in on the street or not like every
kid
gave us more than any other investment
which we which we as a Humanity like
infrastructures and stuff no providing
free education is this like a capital
early on it was a controversial idea
like 100 years ago expensive investment
to give provide education for every kid
expensive investment and we scored a
beautiful world gave a lot to us so
providing a little bit more of the same
can give us unexpected unexpected
results the different perspective is if
we look at majority of the unique
warnings created in the United States
and look at who were the founders of
those and these are companies worth a
billion or more those accomplished Wars
have been enough more or more
they what was it like a big share of
them like a huge most of them
they never struggled as us you know like
they never went through real like
poverty type of situations
money on the bank accounts and stuff
like this you know all the stories about
dropouts from high school
from college
they never had the student that parents
paid for their college and that's how
they afford it yeah the other thing that
gets left out of those stories is when
you drop out of a fancy school they
always let you come back generally it's
not like you burn the ships inside you
exactly so and then the last one no
problem not the last one but the one
also the last one for me then David will
draw something
the struggle will come
it doesn't matter if you have millions
of dollars
you will always be struggling because
like you strive to achieve more
and it's challenging
and
it's not necessary that the struggle is
needed but it will be there and yeah it
doesn't matter if you're like rich or
not like what was this which people also
cry
I'm not gonna wear that t-shirt around
but yeah I mean that's true and the
challenge comes especially when you
start a startup you wanted to succeed
but then I mean also human nature is
human nature like life is suffering it's
gonna find you don't worry
still here exactly you're like with this
argument we hear a lot that founder
should struggle and we personally
struggle a lot through our Founders path
we were like having no resources yeah in
the country where Investments are always
considered as a debt you need to
put as a collateral your house and think
like that
compared to San Francisco
where
there is no lateral
you can have a salary you know in our
case we were prohibited to have a salary
as the founders yeah how you should have
the skin in the game they said so celery
that's hardcore so hardcore Ian if you
compare this experience with Silicon
Valley experience
this is a struggle this is not not
struggle at all and then we see all this
all the unicorns and not from Russia
so most of the successful companies you
know would never exist
without venture capital
without this reason nature capital is
the money in advance is is actually not
struggling struggling is like having the
cash flow and in building your like
bootstrap business most of the companies
are not like that because some levels of
achievements in at least in some areas
they require this freedom for you to
actually risk and to try things in
that's why we believe that some struggle
is needed
but we believe that not on the level
we have right you don't have to
manufacture it yes yes
and there there will always be
competition but student loan which just
stops most of young people in United
States from actually taking risks early
and to achieve more and later and later
I mean I know people in their 30s who
still haven't paid off their you know
and I'm talking not talking early 30s
like mid later 30s especially like an
extended
graduate school or Professional School
are still paying off student debt one of
the individuals this is unneeded
struggle this is really an optimal not
needed
this says
artificial struggle because we know that
the subsidized money
is paid by Tech through taxes by people
but it just spent on the different stuff
somewhere else
so we don't believe in this idea that
the struggle is needed in the vice versa
we believe that
different
local maximum which would be much higher
in terms of the size of the economy
is in the place where we removed some of
the struggles especially those which are
artificial in it just like trying to
imagine what it is 10 times higher
more electricity more power more roads
more cars more education more whatever
More Everything 10 times more everything
this is when the abundance is probably
likely to be close to reality
and that's what we can do in this new
local maximum if we just change the
perspective on whether what's more worse
to invest in the individual income or
the undying companies the companies are
dying like
on average they live actually lessons
like all the statistics is for the
people in their potential but all the
regulations are
exploring for supporters yes
it's obvious why it's this way because
in because in the past we needed this
invention of limit liability companies
in order to like remove the personal
ownership of personal life obligations
individual obligations over the business
like when your ship is sunk in the sea
now you own not only you all of your
money your house but your family can be
taken in the enslaved like we are far
away from this world like hundreds of
years away from this world so now we can
through the innovation of like limited
liability and then the public market and
this is all innovation in in the way how
we see the market
and the way we look at the market but we
are ready for the new innovation
and this new innovation can like uplift
the economy
so question for you guys I'll answer it
first too so what would you
what request would you like to make of
my audience so very very diverse
audience across many countries many
places most of them are interested on
some level in technology not all of them
well let's be honest all humans are
interested in technology they just might
not recognize it as Technologies
is it technology right if we all use
tools that's the reason it's a reason
that homo sapiens have done what they've
done good and bad but
but you know my request from for my
audience would be to send me links to
some of the
biological and biophysics topics that
you both discussed earlier very
interested in all of that
including Quantum effects in and
potentially a bird Vision or well
faction
all of this is of great interest to me
so people can shoot those to me on
Twitter at T Ferris or elsewhere
but what requests
what would you like to make of my
audience or places you'd like to point
them anything at all
two things first
there is a conference about Quantum
biology in near San Diego
in 20th like 18th of August all right
here we go look at that like best
scientists right now are gathering still
like you know like still a quite a small
group of people that's why they really
supportive to each other because they
should compete with each other but they
actually are quite supportive to each
other we will be in the conference as
well
so but what we would ask is actually
to first to think
who would be those individuals you would
invest in
likely all of us have someone who will
like this guy is going to be very
successful second is uh send this
information out to us
so if you know the right person you
would invest you would invest you would
invest your money in like probably will
let us know
in the third one is think that maybe you
should invest in this person as well
you know like maybe it's your kid and
you're a parent and maybe you should
make an agreement and actually invest in
the person or publicly available online
you can all read it and check what's the
closest in there like you can use this
and that's liebermans.com
so
I would say that this is this request so
first think about this people you would
invest in
send out the information about them to
us so what is just being cognizant of
the fact that this is a large audience
so sometimes not good to give out like
your private email I've had people do
that I warned them about it how should
people notify you have these you have a
form perfect
it's humanism
that is humanism is okay humanism.is
and also we communicate quite
extensively through Instagram usually we
you know like we use Instagram not
million people will come listen usually
we we use Instagram not for pictures but
for larger texts in in some of the
instagram.com liebermans liebermans
l-i-b-e-r-m-a-n-s also same spelling
liebermans.com yes just telling you all
right so that's so Instagram
form at humanism.is and people can find
the
agreements liebermans.com
there you have it the other ask can be
we truly want to see this world
happening we need to educate the older
population and the investors and the
grandmas and grandpas who actually are
shareholders stakeholders in the Pension
funds we need to educate
those people who actually own most of
the money in in the country to gradually
start investing in this type of
agreements to at least check to see
what's going to happen in five ten years
from now if they're gonna make more
money by investing in individual income
rather than
private companies public companies and
in this case we will be able to have an
experiment and if it's a successful
experiment we will educate country and
Market to shift towards this yes you can
ask your grandma to look where
are
the pension money
of her
are invested
and to see that probably some companies
will all blame for some
problems problems in the world they can
be the investors that actually companies
which affects our
ecosystem in a bad way they are not
owned by
they actually most of them like 90
percent owned by Pension funds so if we
can educate our like previous
generations that they can be used in the
problem yeah they're not the service
problem or the shareholders in the
future and they have to choose yes
this is the Heritage they can leave
destroying the planet or actually
switching I would imagine 99.9 of them
have no idea that they can control it
that they have a choice yes and they
have yeah that's the funniest part they
can log in and the connection change so
sit down with your grandma maybe look at
their like right in foreign I do want my
some some share of my Pension funds to
be invested on my savings to be invested
in the individuals corporations or in
sustainable companies at least and that
this education should
happen otherwise
there is this belief that they did
previous generation did everything right
in just the new generation is fail but
but it's really important to educate
that some decisions which were made 30
years ago affect us a lot
today in some of this effect can be
changed if we change where the money and
where is the knowledge
yeah
yeah I think a lot of it is
a Communications problem and an
education problem and that
net net humans of different Generations
have more in common than they have
different amongst them but as you
pointed out sometimes the problems
aren't obvious and sometimes
problems aren't discussed and the
options aren't discussed right the fact
that I didn't know this until I mean
shockingly recently for me like 10 years
ago that I could that with retirement
accounts you can invest in properly held
companies and all sorts of other things
it is an option it's just not readily
exploited by most people because they
don't realize that it's on the menu
so I'm excited to see what people come
up to I'm excited to see what people
come up with maybe someone need to make
a startup which actually offers a
solution for the for the pensioners to
do it easier yeah so just the
sustainable companies like that's it
yeah some type of interface that makes
it less manual less one-on-one
because right now it is hard you need to
spend some time to to actually set up
your account properly
but that's the greatest opportunity we
just need all to talk about this if you
have some challenges believing in this
you a you can make your own research on
trying to understand whether we are
right with our data and our points of of
you B you can like you can ask a
question in in the form you can like
find find a way to reach us out and ask
a question so we will explain how we see
this and why we believe this is actually
actually the really really good way of
investing your money well also I mean
you know this conversation has raised so
many good questions I mean one of which
is like how do you take
Capital which is a you know it's a
currency like it's it's it's something
that you can exchange for other things
that is currently locked in a somewhat
static form right that may not be
generating much positive value in the
world and how do you liberate that for
other
faster growing more Dynamic sources of
value right not just for the individual
but for the community for society and I
mean I think about that a lot I mean
it's asset allocation but
on sort of a
karmically considered level at least at
the collective and you don't need to
spend the money which you need right now
yeah it is money which you will only get
access like in 30 years so we made an
experiment when we joined snap it was
first time in our life when we got 401K
first time in a life employed yes yes
acquired us we are employed we now have
401k and the experiment was we're
getting exactly the same salary exactly
the same Savings in the 401k account for
of both of us David
changed everything in his account where
the money is allocated
to towards more sustainable companies
like companies caring about like gambles
and removing the problems of the world
yeah exactly and then monsantes of the
world removing them from there and just
like Shifting the investment towards the
companies which are more sustainable me
I just left everything as it was by
default provided by the Fidelity so far
I earned 20 000 more than Daniel 30 the
gross is 30 higher than mine
so in incest it's just this is the
funniest part so if you believe that
other people believe in the same is that
actually the world is moving in a more
sustainable clean Society you will win
financially as well yes if the shift is
happening if you believe in the shifts
then it should happen otherwise we're
all gonna die but because and because
it's happening like naturally logically
it's happening then you should there
should be a no-brainer that we should
invest in the companies which actually
does this because others will lose in
the market game yeah it doesn't
doing right
morally doesn't need to mean doing
something that is self-destructive yeah
you can align the incentives absolutely
and investing in your kids in your
grandkids is the best thing ever
right so
I think everybody listening has has a
good amount to think about and they have
options for communicating with you they
can go to liebermans.com to see examples
of the agreements right the types of
contracts that have this participation
in future earnings potential and
outcomes of individuals they can go to
humanism.is
to fill out a form
after they think about which of their
friends which of their peer Group which
of their Circle they would most invest
their own savings into
and
they can also consider doing that
themselves with the templates that you
provided we've got the Instagram book
and course for those interested in
exploring coding and the Instagram is
instagram.com liebermans
David
Daniel Danielle
thank you so much for taking the time
today it's awesome absolute pleasure
yeah pleasure so much fun to Traverse so
much ground with you and for everybody
listening
as per usual we'll have extensive show
notes linked to all the resources
everything that was mentioned
and we'll track down a few things here
and there including links to
might have been in the Wall Street
Journal but the sports example
and you can Cruise those at your leisure
at tim.blog podcast and until next time
be a little bit Kinder than is necessary
to others but also to yourself and as
always thanks for tuning in